bon moment il ya là deux qui sont partis
au japon
regardez ces jours michel mr et gilles
verdez alors comment ça s'est passé
chapeau bas c'était extraordinaire et on
a été adoptée par le peuple japonais
c'est vrai vous entrez pour deux des
leurs comptes rapidement mais quand je
vois votre place méritoire
voilà c'est cette partie quand même
temps alors quatre jours quatre jours au
japon c'est fou extraordinaire on a fait
des tas de choses voilà on a été c'est
un peuple et ses excellents et vous avez
partie avec votre chance et vous oui
absolument
françois fatoux bateau ouais c'est ça
ces mules ânes le gard aura su quelle
soirée les aventures de jean michel mr
et gilles verdez au japon regarder un
petit aperçu c'est parti il loge il ne
devait pas nous mettre auxerre classe
touriste si on veut être en baisse et au
lieu de ça on est en cuisine et on est
obligé de ramasser les poubelles de la
viande suis là et c'est bien foutu de
notre gueule
mais pour l'hôtel ça se passera pas
comme ça j'ai tout bétonner mon sens
tout suit royal royal et j'espère même
impérial ce que je peux dire que je
qu'on va ramener des meubles vachon
on a deux suites royales réservés oui
c'est ça c'est ça mais ce soir c'est la
suite d'une bâtisse moi je lance ou non
non non pardon non mme toupin sous mon
nez au lendemain
angie tu ne crois pas au sart merci
série pour sa suite royale a laissé les
gens me à demain tu bouges pas et c est
ce qu on a vu ou pas vu au japon de très
belles geisha dont une qui ressemblait
fortement à gilles verdez oui oui oui
vous y croyez une envie ça c'est du bon
on est bien la regarder ses coffres
d'une paix tu as quoi l'on souscrit ce
moustique
essai
chantre de la guerre
là
on va leur mettre sur la table achetez
du produit je te le dire je les ai
toutes les ressources du job en cinq
minutes a réussi à ruiner le mythe des
geishas ge
deux mille ans de civilisation ruiner en
cinq minutes avait envie à gérard louvin
qui nous a précédés
alors forcément vous allez chez vous
envie de voir le résultat
eh bien on va d'abord regarder jean
michel maire a bien sûr en geisha
regardez ce que ça a donné
jean michel berger maire oui gilles
verdez a donné en douce à regarder
j'espère oui c'est moi
alors gilles bernès il s'est vraiment
très fort je sais pas chez vous mais moi
ils me fout les jetons quand même le
garde j'ai pris des cours de ninja ah
oui ça c'est un truc très secret ah oui
et on a mimé des heures à convaincre les
gens de nous initier
c'est vrai que normalement il n'y a pas
le droit aux personnes serrées on est le
premier occidental depuis 2000 ans ils
seront sur la ligne jade puis de
dégénération des judas c'est un
personnage mais on s'est retrouvé deux
élèves je trouvais que vous ayez nous on
ya quelque chose qui est très bien
regarder deux tonnes de beurre
bizarre
ninja ans cyril ma tante a de vraies et
minja son plateau mokhtar tu peux le
[ __ ] au placard nega au maniement des
armes
c'est une épée socrates a way témoin
origines c'est que ça le magnéto ninja
et ont rêvé mais oui c'est vrai si vous
êtes partis au japon pendant quatre
jours c'est ça que vous avez ramené les
gars nous on a fait quatre heures de
délicieuses quatre heures ont donc deux
images qu'on va garder le meilleur
il y à une fête au japon c'est quoi
ainsi à nagoya c'est une fête religieuse
une fête qui est très importante au
japon
c'est la fête du pénis une célèbre tout
rompre et jolie les femmes et les hommes
se trame avec des lots de sexe et les
femmes les toucher ces gages de fortune
de festivités pour toute l'année et
tourne pas si c'est un truc à creil des
sexes partout et ça et que jean michel
mr et gilles verdez était au centre de
la fusion était très très loin ils ont
même porté le pénis je fais un disque et
regardez ce magnéto il est fou gilbert
des gens missionnaire
regardez c'était au japon bonsoir et
bienvenue dans enquête exclusive vous
allez découvrir un festival unique au
monde qui célèbre le pénis zob pub et
bozize i bienvenue au festival de la
quéquette
ok
une bonne tape pas m'atteindre cyril
jourdan line comme ça qu'ils nous
appellent cet homme en fait elle a une
valeur symbolique
c'est la fête de la fertilité vous la
mettez où vous pouvez bonne fédérateur
voilà
et vive la teub tout ce monde là pour
d'apple
autre niche noire ouest
nous sommes donc maintenant face à ce
pénis de 400 kg beau temps
bah oui aïssa s'arrête net oui au japon
vous n'avez pas de testicules année
prochaine
festival de la couille on peut voir
l'âge de l'acteur en comptant les
stridences on ne peut pas la ramener à
la maison mais franchement le
quadrillage de coeur y était sur
l'atelier au nom est dû après cette
séquence est tout le voyage la bombe de
lourdes aux jaloux c'est pas possible
des actes aussi lourd 400 kg ballet
héroïque 400 kg - vous vous êtes lourd
mais qui sait où on a suffi de rythme
oui bah c'est ça en tout cas bravo
gibert les deux jours du sommet